I love it when the stadium starts to
wake up you come out and nobody be there
that'd just be getting things ready
retirement is funny when you retire from
dave aude 41 I think people thought of
me is saying in my pajamas playing golf
to me I totally believe you drive value
from what you do which are able to
accomplish I was a little timid and
tentative when I first came out of
baseball in the business I have learned
that your gut is very important your
vision is what drives the company so if
you want to build a real sent away
you're going to build a real Wrigley
it's going to live it's going to live
for a long time it has to wash your own
face and that's to be profitable geez
when we started designing complexes we
had specific design ideas and after we
completed those many people would call
and ask us for help in order to have a
really good team to win at the highest
level talent is irreplaceable short of
talent you won't be able to compete you
won't be able to win
the key is about the preparation if you
want to be good you got to practice at
it you got to study they know the other
hitters you know the other pitchers on
the team you got to know the managers
philosophies the more you know then you
have the right chance to the right
opportunities there is just an
opportunity to learn so hit her if
you're really good hitter you fail seven
out of ten times we learn from that and
then you apply it to the next day you
become a better person there's nothing
like I'm using your mind and applying it
to something you love and then having
success at doing it so that's what
drives me and is to say it makes you
come to the ballpark every day with a
renewed enthusiasm and your sorts a
sense of worth that I'm looking for
you